speaking of people that make you laugh
uh sam harris um because he's actually
has a really great sense of humor he
does with a very cold and monotone
delivery he's another one that you had
um you're friends with you have good
conversations with
what um
where's your fundamental disagreements
and agreements with sam sam
believes that religion is intellectually
indefensible he really believes it like
deep in his soul
um
and and he gets angry at the idea
that a proposition
should be unchallenged if it offends his
sense of logic yeah so he cannot move on
until this is done nope in fact uh i i
mean
he you know i did a podcast with eric
weinstein
and then sam did one and sam said when i
heard your podcast with david wolpe
i learned stuff about what he thinks
that i never learned in my conversations
with him because i can never let him
make those unfounded assertions without
challenging them and you just let them
go
and i think that there was something too
that was like
he finds it hard to have
a conversation about religion
that doesn't
arouse his real ire about
the harm that he thinks religion does in
the world so it's more about the
implementation of religion in the world
as it is versus the really fundamental
i think he also thinks it's
fundamentally intellectually shoddy and
disreputable faith yeah faith
i don't know how to put this i mean they
they're both capable of separating their
contempt for religion
from the people that they have sitting
in front of them
you mean christopher hitchens and sam
harris yes both of them
you